bon ça fait des semaines que je reçois
des centaines de messages m'appelant ou
appelant Hugo décrypte en tant que média
à boycotter la Coupe du monde de
football au Qatar la Coupe du Monde
masculine donc qui débute le 20 novembre
et dans cette vidéo je vais donc vous
expliquer la position de Hugo décrypte
en tant que média concernant cette Coupe
du Monde au Qatar et cette question donc
d'un boycott éventuel bon déjà très
rapidement pourquoi parle-t-on de
boycott je ne vous apprends rien la
Coupe du Monde au Qatar accumule les
scandales on peut citer entre autres le
désastre écologique avec notamment cette
stade climatisés les 6500 travailleurs
migrants morts selon de gardiennes ou
encore des droits de l'homme non
respectés et des soupçons de corruption
autour de l'attribution de cette coupe
du monde par la FIFA bref les scandale
sont assez nombreux et j'ai notamment eu
l'occasion de vous en parler dimanche
dernier dans une autre vidéo sur cette
même chaîne Youtube pendant près d'une
demi-heure on s'est plongé dans ses
affaires de corruption et notamment sur
la manière dont la France a aidé le
Qatar à obtenir cette Coupe du Monde bon
le mouvement a ensuite pris de l'ampleur
lorsque certains médias même s'ils sont
très très rares
décidé de boycotter l'événement en
France par exemple le journal local le
quotidien de la Réunion a annoncé qu'il
boycottera l'événement autrement dit pas
l'article ni rien concernant la Coupe du
monde en tout cas sur l'aspect sportif
et au passage aujourd'hui on va se
concentrer sur la question des médias
mais au-delà de ça des villes on boycoté
l'événement en refusant d'installer des
Fan Zone et de très nombreuses citoyens
ont appelé à boycotter et à ne pas
regarder donc cette coupe du monde mais
là donc on va se concentrer sur les
médias bref plutôt que de rester dans le
chou je préfère faire preuve de
transparence et vous expliquer
clairement ma décision sur le sujet Hugo
descript en tant que média aujourd'hui
ne boycottera pas la Coupe du monde
parce que je considère que au-delà de
tous les scandales qui sont bien réels
et qu'on évoque nous-même intensément
depuis des semaines ou des mois sur nos
différents formats et bien je considère
que ce n'est pas le rôle d'un média de
boycotter un événement ou alors un sujet
le rôle d'un média ou d'un journaliste
d'ailleurs c'est d'informer de montrer
des faits et pas de cacher ou de terre
certains sujets sous prétexte que ce ne
serait pas en accord avec ses valeurs
alors cela on peut et on doit même
informer en faisant des choix des choix
par exemple sur l'angle de traitement
d'un sujet comme la Coupe du Monde c'est
ce qui fait que aucun média n'est neutre
en soi parce qu'il y a forcément et bien
des choix dans le traitement qui est
fait de tel ou tel sujet mais simplement
je considère que ça ne passe pas selon
moi par un simple boycott d'un événement
en fait si on considère que c'est une
erreur de parler de la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar alors est-ce que ça veut aussi
dire que c'était une erreur de parler
des Jeux olympiques d'hiver qui se sont
déroulées en Chine il y a quelques mois
en plein scandale donc sur le sort de la
minorité musulmane ouigo en Chine de la
même façon si on prend le planning de
l'année 2023 pour la Formule 1 il y a
des Grands Prix en Arabie Saoudite des
Grands Prix en Chine un Grand Prix
justement au Qatar est-ce que ça veut
dire que là aussi on ne peut pas parler
de la Formule 1 parce que ce serait
contraire à nos valeurs et aux
différents scandales qu'on évoque ici
vous l'aurez compris ça me paraît bien
complexe en fait en réalité pour un
média comme le nôtre son dit les choses
très clairement ce serait assez facile
en fait de boycotter la Coupe du monde
en tout cas ces résultats sportifs parce
que bon le sport c'est pas au cœur de
notre contenu au quotidien vous le voyez
très bien à la limite effectivement ça
pourrait impacter notre compte dédié au
sport sur lequel on poste des résumés
d'actualité liés au sport sur Instagram
mais à part donc ce compte sport qui
reste largement minoritaire par rapport
à toute la quantité de contenu et de
choses qu'on prépare au quotidien boycot
côté ça n'aurait aucun impact négatif
sur notre audience aucun impact négatif
en terme de revenus ou je ne sais quoi
en fait un média il donne à voir il
montre les faits il permet aux gens de
se faire leur propre opinion et plutôt
que de boycotter un média doit plutôt
permettre aux gens de boycotter ou de ne
pas boycotter mais le tout donc en
conscience et en ayant conscience de ce
qui joue actuellement au Qatar
maintenant une fois qu'on a dit ça et
bien je considère quand même qu'on a une
immense responsabilité et qu'on ne peut
pas en parler tranquillement comme ça
relayer les résultats sportifs comme si
de rien n'était et pour dire les choses
dans les prochains jours vous entendrez
beaucoup plus parler des sujets de
société et de ces différences scandales
ent le Qatar que des résultats sportifs
sur Hugo descript les résultats sportifs
et toute l'actualité sportive sera en
fait uniquement ou quasi uniquement
cantonné à notre compte Instagram dédié
au sport et c'est un choix que j'assume
complètement par ailleurs sur ce compte
Instagram dédié aux actualités sportives
qui n'est pas du coup le compte
principal mais qui a un autre compte et
bien même sur ce compte dédié au sport
les sujets et les scandales entourant la
Coupe du Monde au Qatar seront très
régulièrement évoqués ils font l'objet
déjà de postes spéciaux ces derniers
jours dessus Benjamin et Dorian
d'ailleurs qui sont journalistes au sein
de l'équipe qui travaillent sur ces
sujets de sport on travaillait à cela
pour s'assurer que même ceux qui sont là
juste pour les résultats sportifs se
retrouvent aussi informés et au courant
et conscient en fait de ce qui se passe
aussi au Qatar je trouve ça par ailleurs
intéressant de voir comment certains
médias sportifs ont eux aussi intégré
cette question des scandales entourant à
la Coupe du monde je pense par exemple à
la Une de So Foot sortie il y a quelques
jours où ils ont fait un guide pour la
Coupe du monde mais le guide est
intitulé le meilleur guide de la pire
Coupe du monde et à l'intérieur il y a
évidemment l'aspect sportif parce que ça
reste un média dédié au sport et au foot
mais il y a aussi les autres aspects qui
sont traités alors si jamais vous voulez
en savoir plus sur le rôle joué par la
France pour que le Qatar obtienne la
Coupe du monde je vous renvoie à ma
vidéo postée dimanche dernier sur cette
même chaîne Youtube je vous mets le lien
aussi en description si jamais donc vous
les suivre l'actualité au quotidien avec
mon équipe et moi-même y compris
d'ailleurs sur ce sujet on en reparlera
forcément dans les prochains jours dans
le format des actus du jour disponible
chaque jour du lundi au vendredi sur
Youtube je vous mets le lien en
description mais aussi en podcast vous
êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
l'écouter en podcast merci du fond du
cœur pour votre confiance que ce soit
sur Spotify Apple podcast ou autre je
vous souhaite une excellente journée
prenez soin de vous et puis on se dit du
coup à très vite